so you guys are following this old Dylan
Mulvaney's story with Bud Light so
you've seen the whole thing right okay
so check this out okay so Dylan Mulvaney
Bud Light sponsors okay I watched the
interview of the VP of marketing for
bucks as you saw that okay and she
starts off by saying I'm a businesswoman
here's what I'm looking at here's what I
have to do and we looked at the Bud
Light brand it was kind of dying off you
know it was more like the fratty you
know this this set I'm like okay first
of all here's what I pulled up just a
minute ago before we came in what is the
profile of a Beer Drinker let's actually
do that yeah what is the profile of a
Beer Drinker so we went up and we looked
it up 80 of beer drinkers are what men
men of course you can't force a woman to
drink beer if they don't want to yeah
women like
wine women like uh what is the dessert
wine
like okay and by the way that's stupid
that's not me telling you that's stats
when you look at the stats you're not
gonna if you and I right know how to
Rose be kind of weird right okay you
want to have some Rose pan I would say
you're serious bro babysitter you wanna
have a full sun beer you want to have
this a little bit more yeah let's have a
drink to get have a conversation so the
profile of a Beer Drinker
four out of five is male okay it's not
the lgbtq community and then you have to
look at the transgender community and
they'll say well there's about 1.5
million transgenders in America that
identify as a transgender no there's not
the number is so much smaller because
beer drinkers can't be 13 years old gen
Z true yeah beer drinkers have to be
what above 21 you have to be a dummy of
a VP of marketing to say it's true us
targeting to transgender Community more
men are going to want to drink beer you
so so then you go into saying well then
then it's the ESG score so we went
online and we looked at the ESG score
budweis Anheuser-Busch and you notice
they have one of the lowest ESG scores
in America out of all the companies so
she's trying to increase the ESG score
but this is the part about if you ever
read the book Blue Ocean strategy
in Blue Ocean strategy it's a phenomenal
book everybody that's in business should
read it they don't talk about conforming
you try to get into a market that other
people are not unlike yellowtail used to
compete with other wine drinkers and
then they realize their wine sucks yeah
compared to any wine company so
yellowtail went from targeting wine
drinkers to yellowtail one to Target
beer drinkers they took off they went
from selling a few hundred thousand
cases per year to 40 million cases per
year because their their target of
audience was beer drinkers okay so
you're paying two dollars for beer you
can pay six dollars now whatever that
was kind of the way they approach it
it's absolutely insane what some of
these guys are doing so now going back
to your question about do you think
conservative I think that's kind of what
you're asking the question yeah here's
what I will tell you which is awesome
which is absolutely awesome this whole
thing about feminist defending
transgenders you're a is what you
are do you realize how dumb of an
argument that is yeah let me get this
straight feminism was to protect women
yep so I'm a man I decide to think I'm a
woman and I go beat other women in MMA
fights or in swimming you're turning me
into a hero guess what your argument's
about to fall apart right in front of
you by your own people yeah so the the
whole concept of
the whole concept of
um uh you know what's going on right now
with the ideas bad ideas eventually get
support there's a get exposed there's an
actress her name is uh uh what's this
girl's name her name is Sarah Foster I
don't know if you guys know Sarah Foster
is yeah she can't she comes out and she
says the following she says I am a
Democrat okay but she says San Francisco
is turning into a and it's all
because of the democratic policies this
is a woman that's on Vanity Fair saying
this disgusting my heart breaks for the
family I'm a registered Democrat I feel
confident saying liberal politicians are
ruining cities so what does this mean
good ideas eventually get exposed
good talent eventually get exposed Ron
Paul said one of the best things he said
when eventually I became so passionate
about politics when I was a you know I
was a doctor I went to this one guy and
I said listen I can't stop reading this
material I'm obsessed with this content
what do I do he said keep talking about
it the world tends to know how to use
people with the right messages and make
them big you keep talking about it the
right person is going to find you right
sure good policies get exposed good
talent get exposed bad policies also get
exposed and that's exactly what's
happening today which is a beautiful
thing yeah and a lot of people are
paying the price for bad policies today
it's funny you mentioned the feminist
movement and and how it's kind of like
hypocritical what they're doing right
now we had a conversation with both our
sisters yesterday
um because they both work with us at our
marketing agency as well and we're just
like you need to be upset about this
yeah I said I'm upset and he's upset I
said but you guys need to be upset about
this because there's there's so much we
can fight about it right and again
what's a man gonna say to a to a
feminist right but if if women's start
standing up and saying something now
that could be something right what do
you what are your thoughts on that
I think they are but I think what's
happening right now so there's three
different camps there's a camps that the
feminists to them the idea was you know
what that is right you and I are equal I
am just as good as you I should get paid
just as much as you do I should do this
and I should do that I should do this
and the idea seems a noble ideal
and then all of a sudden you're looking
and you're like
um yeah this is kind of not working that
camp and he meant to get out the Vault a
diplomat uh uh six months ago eight
months ago and
I gave a questionnaire to everybody that
night and I said the next day I want you
to come and share with us the biggest
breakthrough you had
one of these girls she's a Persian girl
late 30s very attractive she's kind of
raising Grand like this her sister's
sitting next to her but I haven't seen
her yet but I know she's going like this
she's not going like that there's a big
difference right like you're hoping
don't call Mommy right
So eventually after 10 questions she
goes like this now she really wants to
say so I call on her I said what's the
Breakthrough you had she said
my biggest breakthrough is
I've been competing with men for the
last 30 years and I've been beating them
I make a lot of money
I do very well for myself all my people
make money I'm beating my cousins I'm
beating all these guys
but I'm 39 years old
and all I thought about last night all
night is I want a husband
I no longer want to compete with men wow
I want to marry one and I want to have a
family
this is the beautiful part about
you and I have had many bad ideas before
you know what's the great thing about
parents sometimes they'll see their kid
that has a bad idea and rather than
getting in the way they'll say what go
ahead and see how it does do it yeah and
then you go there and you come back and
say Dad that was a shitty idea I'm glad
you learned yeah and the next one and
you just hope some of the ideas are not
the bad ones that you know you just want
to make sure some of the bad ideas they
go and test
the feminists that bought into that that
now they're older more and more of them
are saying to people I'm 62 years old
I was a feminist now I'm single I've
never been married I don't have any kids
I am so lonely I hate the fact that I
bought into the feminist argument I wish
I would have gotten married I wish I
would have had kids and I realized man
is not my enemy it's so emotional when
you see this because there's nothing
worse than seeing somebody that wasted
their lives yeah and the pain when you
see them you're like man I feel for you
man on what you're going through the
worst thing yeah then there's the other
one where it's kind of like look I want
you to respect me as well I'm not a
feminist I love men I want to get
married but I just want to get some
respect as well and maybe I want to
build a business I want to do this cool
go do your thing as well and then
there's those that are sitting around
saying he said don't know what's going
on I'm just kind of like watching on the
sidelines and now they're starting to
realize this just doesn't make
sense I'm a Democrat I voted for this
but I don't know about this stuff now
it's starting to get a little bit too
much
over the next few years
they're going to get louder and louder
and louder
[Music]